bienvenido al vídeo en el cual vamos a
explicar qué son las funciones cuando yo
aprendí este tema de funciones la verdad
me fue un poco confuso porque pues no
entendía muy bien de qué se trataban y
tampoco entendía por qué se estudiaban
así que en este vídeo espero poder
explicarte un poco de qué se tratan las
funciones y también puedes contarte un
poco porque pueden ser útiles bueno
vamos a empezar con lo siguiente una
función necesita una entrada un valor
que le vamos a dar a ese valor déjame
ponerle x aquí voy a poner una equis y
más o menos la idea de una función es
que es algo así como una caja sorpresa o
sea este valor de x lo vamos a meter
aquí en una caja en una caja que se
llama f así le vamos a llamar a la
función y esa función f lo que hace es
convertir esta equis en otra cosa y
sacar un resultado ya ese resultado que
obtenemos le vamos a llamar f x vale
entonces quizás hasta ahorita todavía
las cosas son un poco confusas porque
hay muchos símbolos esta equis
y fx así que vamos a hacer un ejemplo
concreto imaginemos que lo que hace esta
caja sorpresa es lo siguiente que hace
que a la entrada ósea fx la eleva al
cuadrado y le suma 1 vale entonces esta
es la regleta que tenemos que seguir por
ejemplo supongamos que nos preguntan
quién sf de 2
efe de 2 entonces para respondernos esta
pregunta lo que hay que pensar es que
aquí está entrando un 2 a esta caja y
que aquí está saliendo algún resultado
que ahorita no sabemos quién es pero
para saber quién es simplemente debemos
de poner este 2 aquí arriba y a ver qué
pasa entonces si ponemos el 2 aquí nos
queda 2 al cuadrado que es 4 y si
sumamos 1 nos da silva entonces
efe de 2 sería igual a 5 y me puedes
decir óyeme esto nada más es una forma
más complicada de sustituir un valor en
una ecuación o en una expresión y bueno
si hasta ahorita te voy a dar la razón
pero puede ser que una función sea una
expresión
más general que una ecuación a qué me
refiero por ejemplo imagínate que
tenemos la siguiente función tenemos la
función
fd x fx es igual le voy a poner aquí x
cuadrada más 1 si x es pan si x es
y voy a ponerle aquí abajo x cuadrada
menos 1 si x es impar si x
y muy bien entonces observa esto de aquí
es algo nuevo no simplemente nos dice
cuál es la expresión que tenemos que
evaluar sino que además nos da
instrucciones de dependiendo el valor de
x lo que tenemos que hacer por ejemplo
si aquí nos piden calcular cuánto es
efe de 2 efe de 2 entonces tendríamos
que utilizar el primer caso cuando x
spark y nos quedaría igual a haber 2 al
cuadrado es 415 a eso ya lo habíamos
hecho antes pero si pusiéramos aquí
efe de 3 entonces ahora tendríamos que
hacer 3 al cuadrado y restarle 1 en el
segundo caso entonces 3 al cuadrado es 9
si restamos 1 nos quedaría 8 muy bien
entonces como ves esto es algo un
poquito más abstracto o un poquito más
inusual que en la que el ejemplo
anterior vale bueno vamos a ver otros
ejemplos quiero darte un ejemplo un poco
raro o un poco este abstracto para pues
contarte un poco más de qué se trata
esto de las funciones realmente hay
muchas cosas en el mundo que se puede
y pensar como funciones a lo mejor es un
poquito confuso pero no te preocupes si
te confundes en realidad los problemas
que nos van a poner o que ponen en los
exámenes son más sencillos bueno pero
para mostrarte que es una idea más
general déjame pensar en esta función
que le voy a llamar leo leo yo me llamo
leo vale entonces esto va a ser la caja
sorpresa y vamos a pensar qué sucede si
le ponemos como entrada a esta función
que se llama leo comida comida
comida entonces que puede producirle o
habita no me voy a meter en todas las
cosas que puede producirle o más bien
quiero quiero decir algo específico
entonces lo que me voy a preguntar es
quién es leo o qué es leo de comida
comida y bueno si tú me das de comer
entonces yo puedo producir vídeos
traducidos de la academia kahn entonces
déjame ponerle por aquí vídeos vídeos de
la academia kahn traducidos
lúcidos traducidos vale entonces misma
idea entra comida y salen vídeos de la
academia kahn traducidos claro a lo
mejor además de poner comida necesitamos
pues aquí una computadora verdad una
computadora computadora para realmente
poder producir los vídeos en fin vamos a
pensarlo así bueno vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo vamos a poner ahora la función
to digo podría poner tu nombre no lo sé
estaría padre saberlo pero déjame
ponerle nada más tú entonces qué sucede
con contigo o sea que sucede con ahora
la función que se llama tú vamos a
pensar qué sucede cuando de entrada
tiene vídeos de la academia cam vídeos
de la academia kan traducidos voy a
poner nada más así atrás traducidos
bueno pues con un poco de suerte si si
entran vídeos de la academia cana ti
pues vas a aprender cosas y con eso vas
a sacar exámenes con 10 entonces lo voy
a poner aquí
y exámenes exámenes como
con 10 de calificación le voy a poner
tus exámenes si no los exámenes de tus
amigos ni de nadie más sino tus exámenes
con 10 va ahora bueno sabes que déjame
aquí quitar la computadora para pensar
en lo siguiente imagínate que ahora lo
que queremos hacer es lo que es
preguntarnos el resultado de la
siguiente operación se imagínate que
queremos ver quién sería tu de leo de
leo de comida comida va esto de aquí ya
se está poniendo un poco ridículo pero
sigue la corriente tantito porque esto
tiene una idea interesante detrás
entonces ve ya sabemos que leo de comida
es vídeos de la academia que han
traducido y sabemos que tú de vídeos de
la academia kahn traducidos es que tus
exámenes tienen 10 o que puedes producir
sus exámenes con 10 de calificación
entonces qué pasaría aquí que obtenemos
y hacemos tú de leo de comida pues bueno
aquí adentro tendríamos que ver quién es
leo de comida entonces esto que no
sabemos cuánto es pues primero tenemos
que ver cuántos leo de comida van a
poner por acá leo de comida
y ya sabemos que esto es vídeos vídeos
de la academia con traducidos entonces
tú de leo de comida sería lo mismo que
tú de vídeos vídeos de la academia con
traducidos y tú de vídeos ya sabemos
cuánto es tú de vídeos es que en tus
exámenes sacas 10 entonces puedes
producir tus exámenes exámenes
con 10 con 10 muy bien entonces tú de
león de comida es que es producir tus
exámenes con 10 eso está padrísimo y si
aquí en vez de comida le pusiéramos otra
cosa no sé si en vez de comida pensamos
que aquí le ponemos veneno pues se haría
algo muy distinto verdad aquí en vez de
que entre comida entraría veneno
tendríamos que ver cuánto es leo de
veneno veneno entonces que podría
producir yo si me das veneno pues no sé
pero definitivamente no serían vídeos de
la academia kahn traducidos y entonces
sería muy distinto
no no no te recomiendo que me des veneno
bueno ok entonces a lo mejor este
ejemplo es un poco raro pero pero no te
preocupes social si no lo entendiste
nada más la idea es ver que hay más
cosas en el mundo que pueden servir como
funciones vamos a hacer mejor un ejemplo
ahora sí con números y con expresiones
siguiendo estas mismas ideas no sé
imagínate imagínate que nos dicen que la
función f
fd x es igual a x + 2
y que la función de x es igual a pues le
voy a poner x cuadrada menos 1 entonces
pregunta cuánto sería g de f de 3 como
le haríamos para calcular esta expresión
le voy a poner aquí un signo de
interrogación pues misma idea primero
tenemos que evaluarlo de aquí adentro
que es efe de tres déjame hacer este de
tres aquí al lado entonces teníamos que
ver cuánto es efe de tres y para eso
sustituimos tres en esta expresión 3 + 2
sería 5 trias 5
entonces gdf de 3 sería igual a g de 5 y
ahora este 5 lo podemos sustituir en
esta expresión en esta función para ver
que nos queda entonces nos quedaría 5 al
cuadrado menos uno que es 25 menos 1 o
sea 24 y de esta forma sabemos que g df
de 3 es igual a 24 muy bien bueno espero
que estas ideas te ayuden un poco a
comprender esto de las funciones
espero no haberte espantado mucho con
este ejemplo de los vídeos traducido
y de la comida y del veneno en fin en
los siguientes vídeos vamos a ver un
poco más de ejemplos y bueno con un poco
de suerte en el camino entenderemos un
poco mejor de qué se trata esto de las
funciones bueno hasta la próxima